j'entendrai toute ma vie les hurlements
eu frappe le Juif
bjidov des hurlements et des fracas de
verre et de meubles qu'on a laissé par
terre il faut se mettre dans euh l'état
de chose qui était euh en Russie à ce
moment-là en 1905 cela a commencé par la
fameuse Constitution ou la prétendue
constitution arraché ZAR je me souviens
très bien être allé à l'école ce jour-là
nous étions tous en liè nous ne
comprenions pas grand-chose mais on nous
a expliqué que tout allait changer que
les choses seraient beaucoup mieux pour
tout le monde et en particulier pour les
Juifs et là-dessus après nous avoir
distribué le journal on nous a donné
congé une chose dont on se souvient
toujours et alors l'aprèsm midi nous
avons vu des cortèges qui défilaient
dans les rues de la ville et qui se
rendaient presque tous sur une grande
place où ils étaient accueillis comme
vous le devinez par les cosacs par
l'armée à
cheval et le soir on s'est aperçu
d'autres choses presque tous les coins
de rue
et
était était rassemblé des et des civils
qu'on ne connaissait pas qui venaient
sans doute de la province qu'on a fait
venir de la province et qui se mettait à
attaquer tous les Juifs qui qui
passaient par là mon père il compris il
en a perdu son chapeau et il est arrivé
tout affoué nous disant il y a quelque
chose qui se prépare fermons vite le le
portail et en effet on a fermé le on
avait un grand portail de fer qu'on a
fermé
et au cours de la nuit qui a suivi nous
avons pu sauver une vingtaine de
malheureux qui avaient été blessés
jeunes vieux surtout des vieux qui
avaient été blessés qui ont pu se
traîner jusque là parce qu'on on leur
faisait signe on les le faisait entrer
et nous avons eu 3 jours et tr nuits de
terreur j'entendrai toute ma vie les
hurlements frappe le
juifov des hurlements et des fracas de
ver et de meubles qu'on a laissé par
terre nous vivions alors tous cachés
dans le dans la cave tous à l'exception
de ma mère et de son dernier NZ qui
avait peur de l'obscurité elle se
promenait toute seule dans la cour si
avaient si les ém avaient pu y entrer il
été la première
victime heureusement qu'ils n'y sont pas
entrés ils n'y sont pas entré parce que
un coup de feu est parti d'un immeuble
voisin alors immédiatement la populace
s'est dirigée là-bas et ce qui s'en est
suivi vous le devinez vous-même quand 3
jours
après on a dit ça y est ça y est c'est
fini c'est fini et nous avons pu aller
jusqu'au portail je n'ai plus reconnu la
rue on aurait dit il avait nger parce
que les émtiers avaient jeté toute la
literie qui était donc la rue était
toute blanche des il y avait des tables
des chaises des pianos tout était jeté
et on nous avait dit aussi le le le
nombre don je ne me souviens pas de
victimes qui avaient péri dans cette
immeuble là c'était dans quelle ville
monsieur c'était à Kiev à keV en octobre
1905 mais pour être juste et pour
continuer notre conversation nous avons
eu un un mini ome avant et après ce
grand pogrome chaque matin que le bon
Dieu faisait nous étions attaqués en
allant à l'école par des par des bandes
de petits Russiens ou de petits
Ukrainiens qui nous battaient comme
plâtre quand ils étaient plus nombreux
que nous parce que nous nous défendions
et qui nous annonçait qui nous prévenait
à la fin du mois on vous égorgera tous
il va soit qu'ils ont entendu dire cela
par parents et les parents le tenaient
des gens de la
[Musique]
Douma